what's your take on a filmmaker putting
themselves in a major role in their film
if they can act sure why no I mean we
have some sort of extraordinary examples
of that mr. wells for one yeah why not I
wouldn't do it I'm not going to jump in
front of the camera except for air for
this for this sort of experience I don't
think that that's my skill and I also am
very involved with tempo I the the the
key grip pointed out to me that during
each take I was counting that he could
see my fingers counting and I had no
idea I was doing it no idea and when he
told me this I said no I don't and
everyone laughed because everyone had
noticed that I was doing that and I was
I was observing I was feeling the tempo
of the of the shot and I think that that
would be very it would be impossible for
me to do if I were in the shop when you
say tempo can you tell us more about the
rhythm is the scene is it fast enough is
it too fast
is it is it in the rhythm of the rest of
the movie and this is organic this is
not buy is not something I'm thinking
about it's like the way characters
appear to me this is something that I
simply do really not being aware of it
as I'm doing it
so you lieutenant it was almost like a
metronome exactly yes
you